so i want to show you this one of the
big narrative bits that's been coming
out around these protests is that
white supremacists have been secretly
disguised as black lives matter
well we have this tweet from jared holt
and i must say
if jared holt is saying right now
there's been no evidence to suggest this
is true
it doesn't mean it's not true i take his
word for it jared holt writes for right
wing watch
it's a progressive it's part of a
progressive advocacy organization
and he writes about the right and from a
left perspective he's very biased
but he's come out and even said on
tuesday i asked richmond police
and the richmond mayor's office to
provide information to support the
claims they made to this outlet
that white supremacists instigated riots
in their city they have not responded my
request
other outlets have asked for this
evidence too and have similarly come up
with nothing
richmond officials have presented no
direct evidence showing white
supremacists organized the protest
encouraged violence or participated in
any property damage
okay if this guy's job is to write about
this stuff
yeah and i think he's biased but he even
he's saying
they've presented no evidence then i
think that's where we're at so far
there's no point in going around with
the narrative claiming it's true
now jared i believe he does go on to say
though it could be true
if they're drafting up uh indictments
they're not going to release evidence
he says this story quotes a spokesperson
for mayor levar stony
who said police were still investigating
and more arrests were suspected
uh were expected you know what the
problem with this though
this this is the issue you you think a
white supremacist
everyone just instantly thinks far right
but
far left people can be white
supremacists also they are
in the end they certainly are i mean
that's what we're seeing the challenge
is colloquial understanding yeah they're
trying to connect
the the far right you know classic what
they would say a white supremacist but
in reality
they're very much far left white
supremacists
and that's that's kind of what it feels
like they're ignoring because
that's what we're seeing sure sure and
and i tweeted about this
i said something like if jared is the
one saying that they've not got no
evidence as of right now then i take his
word for it because
it's literally his beat if he saw even
if if he saw like a tiny tiny morsel of
white supremacy he'd be like there it is
i found it yeah i mean so if he's not
seeing it
but people immediately were like i
thought antifa were white supremacists
tim i'm like yes yes yes yes yes
but come on the the colloquial
understanding of what they're saying
right is they're trying to insinuate
specific groups of people are dressing
up like antifa to go out and make antifa
look bad
that's the specific claim if there's no
evidence of it then i'm glad
it's it's being at least for now not
necessarily debunked
but like stopped you know if if they're
actually going to issue arrest if
they're going to you know make these
claims
they should present evidence before
coming out and just saying this nonsense
because it basically makes everybody mad
i mean
we're asking the media to like present
evidence for things that they're
claiming
i mean that's that had me giggling come
on that's pretty funny
really well hold on hold on this is why
it's really funny
you'd think the media would be at least
one step above
a political like a progressive advocacy
organization okay
but that's why i think it's it's kind of
funny to see jared holt whose
whole thing is like reporting on the
right
to be like where's the evidence and the
local media being like the police said
it there it is
like here's the story don't you need
like three confirmed sources before you
can publish something as a fact
no they read headlines saying white
supremacists secretly organizing riots
says police i saw the words on the
internet it's true
yup it must be true it used to be before
you published you had three sources to
confirm it
does that is that how it used to be
right it used to be well i
don't want to speak for every single
news outlet but typically yeah yeah so
it used to be like if someone told you
they saw a brick
you know hit a cop in the head you'd be
like what's your name can i put you on
the record
then you'd walk to another person you
get three sources to confirm we all saw
this you'd be like i got three people
saying it they're all independent of
each other yeah and the same was true
for basically a bunch of other stories
you can't just if someone tells you
something you can't be like well this
guy said it was true so it is
you'd be like can independent sources
corroborate the claim yeah they don't do
that anymore
the police said it therefore we report
it and instead of instead of doing any
due diligence they just say
police say and there's your headline
police say
they do this all the time with tons of
stories they'll just be like
you know you know it's really funny when
they have anonymous sources
is the best part so it'll be like
anonymous source claims donald trump is
secretly you know putting poison in dog
bowls throughout the city of you know
throughout dc
or or someone close to donald trump says
that this is happening no no no no i've
got a specific point they'll say
an anonymous source claims you know
donald trump
threw a brick at the face of his
assistant okay and you'll be a lot
people will read the story and go whoa
and then
you have to imagine how the story was
actually sourced there's a dc beat
reporter with a notepad standing in an
alley
and there's a guy with in like you know
covered in garbage just going and
donald trump you know get a backflip off
the white house and then i saw me
through a brick
he threw a brick and then he just like
walks into a wall
falls down and he goes and they're like
he said it that's confirmed to me
anonymous source claims it's like yes
but is your anonymous source the guy
who's drugged out in the alley freaking
out
spouting gibberish yeah and what part of
that did you leave out
like before he's like he says donald
trump is a lizard person who threw a
brick
at his advisor and then jumped off the
building and flew away in outer space
and he cuts off the beginning of the end
and just says donald trump threw a brick
or it was a phone brick and the advisor
was actually playing catch with them
it was a football but yeah football
i mean they do this stuff all the time
right it'll be like donald trump was
throwing objects at his staff earlier
today
no he was throwing objects at a teenager
yeah
in the white house lawn but it's they're
just throwing catch
playing baseball it'll be like the
disabled son of a military vet
was visiting the white house when donald
trump began throwing objects at him
and that that's the narrative yeah and
you'll see a photo and he's like just
he's throwing a baseball and the kid's
catching it
like gets in a wheelchair or something
that's how the media rolls man yep
i'll tell you what we got this story
here there apparently are some white
supremacists in portland
that's right the wall of moms are racist
oregon live says
portland wall of moms crumbles amid
online allegations by former partner
don't shoot pdx oh that's the name of
the
former partner look at this important
announcement from wall of moms
i'm i'm not going to read this to
everybody but they basically said
it's anti-blackness and not to support
the wall of moms
wow wall of moms white supremacy
confirmed
so all of those i'm sorry wait that's
only one source tim
oh no i'm sorry you're incorrect good
sir this is
i'm using the oregon live a trusted news
guard certified
organization therefore what they say is
law
ah okay yeah okay good i don't really
think the wall of moms are a bunch of
white supremacists
that's the joke yeah but the point is
they're being accused of being white
supremacists because the only thing
these lectures or
these left-wing organizations can do is
accuse you of being
white supremacist racist anti-black
whatever
and so now you get it here you go
congratulations i don't know what this
x is supposed to be makes it hard to
read import oh okay i see
the wall of moms published the statement
they x'd it out and then said
edit for everyone upset about the post
we are not against moms
everyone has a place in organizing we
are no longer in support of
womb leadership anti-blackness do not
support wall of moms
after leaving vulnerable black women
downtown after marching oh you know i'm
not going to read it i'm not going to
read it thank you
thank you you know why you know why
they're they're immediately trying to
drum up racism where there is none
yep they're having a dispute because i
guess someone got kicked off a social
media account
so what happens they say well they
left people behind it's like we we
talking about well it's anti-blackness
they said
don't support them they're racist the
lies are finally clear
and we are sad but ultimately not
surprised that anti-blackness showed its
ugly head
what read them hearing them say the lies
are finally clear is
is pretty funny come on yeah what do you
what do you do when when they're
accusing each other of being racist and
fighting each other
drama unfolding lots of us are trying to
regroup and do things the right way
i mean you know they do act rather
racist i mean they're racist
yeah that's the stupidest story ever i'm
not surprised though look
i'll tell you what jared holt says
so far they haven't released in i
believe it was richmond evidence that
white supremacists were actually
organizing
yeah well i got some new evidence for
you oh goodness according to don't shoot
pdx the wall
of moms are engaging in anti-blackness
that makes that i don't like
supremacists yes that makes wall of moms
the white supremacists
therefore in i believe it's this video
you can see the yellow those are those
are the white supremacists
oh so they came out last night yeah
they're there they're they're in the
videos
yeah so you can you can see some of them
they wear yellow helmets and yellow
shirts and there they are
the uh it's like wearing a medic the
guys with the metacrosses on there
they're not medics
some of them are i've seen i've seen
them in the in the front pushing
and pushing at the cops so that's not
what a medic does the medical holding
back to help people if they get hurt
there are medics they wear red crosses
okay
and there are journalists they were
press and antifa learned
how to engage in propagandistic warfare
by doing exactly that so they'll pretend
to be medics and they'll pretend to be
you know uh filmers so what you're
saying is
i'm right well you can't make it sound
like
every single medic is secretly anti-fog
because there's that's what you're here
for tim
right excellent yeah so good teamwork
buddy
if if you even so in like uh
i i'd be willing to bet for the most
part if you're on the right
and i've seen this happen if you're like
a trump wearing a trump hat and you get
hit in the head with a brick one of
these medics will come to your aid and
they will help you
straight up so it's not however the
problem is you don't know
when antifa is pretending to be a medic
and then going i'm american
i'm a medic you can't arrest me and they
get arrested and then they say the
police arrested medics and journalists
that's why i get really annoyed by these
journalists who scream at the top of
their lungs at police
if you man if you you can't do this to
me journalists like dude
listen you're another random person in
the crowd you need to be aware of your
surroundings
and you need to know what the police are
going to do when they're going to do it
and stay out of their way
yes you have a right to film and record
but you can't expect a human being to
act like a robot
with programming being like boop it says
press therefore
sorry sir you're free to do whatever you
want especially when antifa
literally walks around there's a photo
of a guy wearing press on his helmet
waving the ante for flag
he's not a journalist he has no camera
they do it on purpose
they also put walls of moms in front of
them
so that when when when the cops move in
they say oh they're help they're
attacking the moms
how dare they i'm gonna tell you i'm
secretly oh wait it's not his name
kate brown the state police i'm gonna
tell you what i'm gonna do
what are you gonna do i am forming an
organization oh goodness called the weak
and vulnerable elderly grandmothers
oh man i'm i'm a little disappointed i
wanted it to be the wall of tim's
nope and vulnerable elderly grandmothers
will be the name of our group it's going
to be comprised of a bunch of 25 year
old very big burly right-wing trump
supporting men
and then when they put on an event
celebrating trump and antifa shows up
the media will be forced to report
antifa threatens and attacks weak and
vulnerable elderly grandmothers
you see how it works i do i like it yeah
sneaky i love it how they're like we're
anti-fascist therefore like you're dumb
if you think that we're actually
fascists
and it's like well apparently you're
authoritarians and now you're being
accused of being white supremacists so
what am i supposed to call you it's not
a good look it's like
you they call themselves like the good
guys therefore you can never accuse them
of wrongdoing
but uh we're the good guys it's our name
duh
well there it is okay fine the weak and
elderly the weak and vulnerable elderly
grandmothers
antifa beats and and chokes weak and
vulnerable elderly grandmothers
wall of beanies wall of weak and elderly
grandmothers
weak and elderly all right well
that's basically portland thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you